getting pregnant you don't really have  much of a choice if you're pregnant and  you're gonna have a kid then  you're immediately a healthy sober  person  as a man if you're good and you're there  then it's one thing but as a woman if  you're breastfeeding then you're just  completely attached to the baby for like  a year it probably actually ended up  speeding up my career because it put the  partying on hold  which is a funny thing to say about  having kids my observation for young  people  in university was that for example the  students i had  who were studying psychology who also  started working in a lab and then so  we're working 12 or 20 hours extra a  week  got better grades doing more things well  because they had to discipline  themselves and they quit wasting time  yeah and there's some real utility in  shouldering the sort of responsibility  that stops you from wasting time